[Music]
you know how earlier today we were
talking about how they're scammers and
they're [ __ ] and then how I
mentioned in that video that we're gonna
be talking about someone who yes okay
well this is the video now so this guy
this is California taxi driver saved a
92 year old woman from getting scammed
out of 225 thousand dollars all right so
when she wasn't his cab uh he heard her
talking to someone on the phone I don't
know when she got in the cab she said
that she needed to go to the bank oh my
god
yeah and then she had to pull out a
large amount of money and so he was like
do you like what happened or why and
then the woman said that there was
someone that was calling her and saying
that she owed money to the IRS and then
she asked like wait do you know this
person and she was like no I don't know
this person so that's when he was
pleading with the woman to reconsider
drawing this money out of the bank and
he he was like I really think that this
is a scam and that's when she like she
was not believing him that could have
been a scam she I want to get in trouble
at this point I would have been like you
deserve to be scared there's ninety two
they don't know yeah but she was
probably riding horses Jojo what it's
gotta be 89 89 so why is it that people
think the older someone is the more
stupid they are the expiration date my
friend and then she comes from a time of
different times yeah it was love TV but
she's been around longer than all of us
in her day with someone was committing a
crime on her they said reach for the sky
[Laughter]
that's in her day I know I show my
grandma like pictures on my laptop I
show my grandma pictures of my uh on my
laptop and it she look at the CD slot
she's like is that where you put the
pictures do you even understand that you
can scan when you're telling me they
don't have a brain no door they can
[ __ ] put the thing and go
does it work to a bank right and he's
like everybody get down then everybody
kind of gets up except for grandma
except for grandma grabbers like
withdraw teleported to a thousand years
from today and then and then like they
expect you to use their technology and
they're like ah look at this idiot
doesn't know what I'm saying is this
technology didn't fall from the sky she
was alive every step of the way we were
have a comment I feel like my mom would
get scammed with this because um she's
so gullible and she always wants to do
the right thing she's like Miss goody
two-shoes so she wants to meet that like
she hates being late she hates all that
stuff but gullible can be any age okay
so she's a gullible older they don't
understand she's like my dad my dad just
you know he has a smartphone
they've only got the smartphone's the
past couple years so he'd be going on
porn and [ __ ] on a smartphone right he
started getting these pop-ups
he's [ __ ] he sees this [ __ ] was like
your phone needs to be you got a virus
he clicks on that [ __ ] cuz he thinks
it's legit yeah right he's on my dad is
he telling your mom he's like yeah oh no
click on that [ __ ] it's all me was like
yeah you know like I went on what is
credit card for me no no he doesn't pay
for anything he just he went on a couple
website he's smart down but you also
have to know scams at her age back in
whatever she was we're different than
they are now that's true it was like get
Chagas fake down okay everything yeah
this game is different so she thinks
like why would they scam this way it's
to marry Alexa you can fly a little bit
you just put it on your hands we're not
hands hit in there like you come over
here your arm is missing [ __ ] you doing
okay try to [ __ ] rub me out of his
[ __ ] job
okay back to the story
that's when the taxi driver talked to
the woman and finally convinced her he
convinced her to let him call the number
of the person who was posing as an IRS
employee yes so then when he called the
number he says that he asked the man do
you know this lady
he said no so then that's when he said
that he knew something was wrong and
then that's when he continued to press
the man and telling him telling him that
the woman was 92 years old and then she
was nervous and so the man hung up and
that's when the taxi driver kept calling
him back like repeatedly and then
eventually the number blocked him and
that's when but the woman still at that
point what was it like she didn't
believe the driver yet deserves it
dude dude how smarty though if I'm 92
I'm opening up credit with everybody I'm
like what are you gonna do I'm dead in
three weeks
it's families 90 something ask years old
self can it can [ __ ] manage and live
life forget assistance and then there
was it it wasn't there like mothers be
about someone that was abusing him oh
don't say that Richard Timmons no
Stanley okay so this is a better
conspiracy about that she's to me I see
a stubborn person she's refusing till
she's scared she's refusing to it's
different when you're not connected to
what's going let me continue the story
tell us
gonna pay to stop interrupting tip let
her tell doesn't please the story it
should be interrupted literally the
timeline of the show anyway but so
that's when the driver finally pleaded
with the woman and said can I please
take you to a police station
maybe you'll believe a cop so she's
finally who is this guy he's nice yeah
he's spider-man so then she finally said
okay let's go to the police department
he spoke to an officer at the station
explained everything and that's when the
officer finally convinced a woman that
yes she was being scammed and that's
when the driver was like okay oh I see
this lady because there's like I'm a
really honest man like I knew something
was wrong
good for him whether you can't driver
them they always they always come on
different country and he's trying to
provide for his family it's still back
home I know the whole story well he came
from a different country
I just made that up well he is Raj Raj
beers thing so yes he's an Indian cab
yeah he's like mad we used to do these
scams all the time in India
I know these cons ma'am and you know
it's cute this old lady was she the only
believe the police officer because back
in her day people in uniform were like
the upright citizen or what a physical
it lady is [ __ ] racist the whole time
how would your engine ass know anything
about our government function
how is it possible that I'm talking to
an engine but I'm not unless you
wouldn't believe it that would be crazy
yeah in the end he took her home yeah
bank account was same and then a week
after she gave it to the a week after
Raj got a call to come back to the
station and when he got there the
officers gave him a $50 gift card to
thank him for with gift card to what
she's cake factory they follow me
probably not you can only buy like bread
there are you know what Tim probably
Boston Market Boston Market
maybe was a I mean not yeah so she
always there's tips look on the bright
side as always she almost transferred 25
grand
no withdrew yes no she almost read it to
the paper real scan that's happening
right now so a lot of scammers right now
are getting old people too they get them
on they do screen sharing right and then
what one of the things that they do is
they get them to download this applet of
a program that it's almost like an
ms-dos thing but it it's like in the
black window right and it doesn't matter
but it plays and then in the screen it
says like oh well here's the amount of
money that you should pay so they're
like hey you should pay this much money
in order to get your your computer back
from the virus
oh so people start to type it and then
the scammer already has screen sharing
on with typing on so they add a zero to
whatever they write so usually goes from
like you know like a thousand bucks or
something to 10 grand and they just add
the zero at the end of it and hit enter
and then it says applicate and so then
they're like wait oh you just we just
paid you 10 grand
you owe us this money now and so then
the scared person is like oh [ __ ] what
am I gonna do and they end up having to
go to the bank to try to settle the
payment so they feel they're like well
should I owe them 9 grand because
because if they put it into our town
zactly
that's the thing that's actually
happening dude when I moved to LA about
two years into it my buddy was breaking
up with his girlfriend I had to find a
new roommate and so when I was looking
for a new roommate on Craigslist one of
the main scams was oh hey you need a
roommate cool I'm gonna move in with you
um is it cool if I just send all my
furniture to you I'm gonna send you it
I'll give you a check right now for five
grand and then all you have to do is put
that into a new bank account and then
you send me a Western mutant check for
five grand and bounces of course the
check bounces but I already sent them a
check from my funds that says five grand
from Western you why do people send it
without the check clearing exactly what
people do it because maybe they don't
know how the bank system works yeah I
mean maybe talk to them like 12 or 13
times so they think they're reputable
people yeah when I was looking for
apartments on Craigslist once there was
this other scam where they were saying
that they own that piece of property
that was inquiring about and that if I
would just send in the deposit and they
will leave the key in the mailbox and
all this other [ __ ] and I remember
responding like you really think I'm not
stupid
have you guys heard of the truth default
theory so the truth default theory is
the theory that generally humans trust
people first until they're given a
reason that this person is lying after
until there's enormous evidence people
don't go hey wait a minute
I'm except wait a [ __ ] minute [ __ ]
everybody mother give me evidence that
you're telling the truth I don't do that
you're a piece of [ __ ] well you know why
because I think people are afraid to
unveil that it just might be filled up
with a lot of cons but it's also
evolutionary so the concept is that if
humans were constantly skeptical of each
other it there's not tried building
there's no progress there's like
whatever right so what ends up happening
is that there's no there's nothing
that's really being built but if you
just trust each other first and foremost
then you kind of just follow the leader
you kind of just listen and all this
stuff it just keeps going dude I was
just
movie premiere but if I met Chris Pratt
and I was like you're probably not even
Chris Pratt
oh [ __ ] that's how [ __ ] ready I am
cam hey you know what's the funny part
of it is you don't even meet him you
walk right buddy I met a man she's lying
I don't so shook his hand like we're
friends
[Music]